هجوم كبير يتعرض له مسلسل كبير قوي الجزء
السابع بعد عرض حلقاته الاولى حيث انتقد
عدد كبير من رواد مواقع التواصل شخصيه
مربوحه التي تجسدها الفنانه رحمه احمد
وتمت اتهامها بالمبالغه في الاداء فرغم
النجاح الكبير الذي حققته شخصيه مربوحه في
الموسم السادس للمسلسل الا انها في الموسم
الحالي تعرضت الى انتقادات وهجوم جعل
الفنانه الشابه تتصدر محركات البحث خلال
الساعات الماضيه فيما اعتبر البعض ان هذا
التحول الكبير من الاشاده الى الهجوم
القاسي وحمله ممنهجه ضد الفنانه رحمه احمد
من بينما الفنان هشام اسماعيل الذي عبر عن
ذلك على حساباته على مواقع التواصل ايضا
ناقد الفني طارق الشناوي اعتبر ان هذا
الهجوم غير منطقي وتقييم غير منصف وجائر
كما عبر المنتج محمد العدل على فيسبوك عن
اعجابه بالشخصيه والاداء معتبرا ان
المبالغه مطلوبه في مثل هذا العمل